now our next for our next guest uh
shamima begum circumstance may seem all
too familiar tanya joya married one of
the most senior commanders
of so-called islamic state an american
white man
before turning her back on the group and
fleeing syria in 2013
for the sake of her children tanya now
admits she was young
naive and the utopia she longed for
simply didn't
exist she now lives in texas with her
children and new partner and she joins
us live
from there now good morning to you
uh you must be following the case of
shamima bagan with a huge deal of
interest because you found yourself
in a similar situation
yes um absolutely and i
feel that i probably would have made the
same mistake as she did
if i was 15 year old 15 years old and in
her situation
and i can only hope that we can
rehabilitate her
and teach her about secular humanism and
our western principles because i don't
believe
that she was taught that to begin with
and most
most conservative muslim homes do not
teach
um humanism and secular values
we're usually taught to fear god and
god's law
overrides every every other law the rule
of law of any country man-made law
and i feel like she doesn't understand
that there are other ways of thinking
and and a form of justice i don't think
she
she's so young that she hasn't done the
research like
the psychology of of human beings and
of like why people do the things they do
it's not
right now she's thinking very binary and
everything has to be like
life or death and also
with people like shamima and the
situation i was in when i was younger
is that we were deceived to believe that
this life is a dream and it's not real
and that the afterlife after we die
that's the real existence
yeah it's all alive explain to us what
explain to us what life was like because
you went to syria with your husband you
were both
radicalized what was life like when you
got there
well for five years before i went to
syria
i was struggling with my faith i didn't
want to wear the hijab
i wanted americans to not feel that i
was a threat because i really
loved the people my society i love i
learned
about american values and not just
american values but western values
that i didn't learn growing up as a
child
i learned to appreciate freedom and what
it really meant
and and these values like freedom of
thinking it's not
i believe that shimama was in a
situation very similar to my own
where we weren't allowed to have that
freedom to think
for ourselves we weren't allowed to be
independent-minded
women she still ran away to join she ran
away to join an
organization that she admits herself she
knew beheaded
people and and she's asking for sympathy
from the british people and you know a
lot of the reactions
she should be asking for mercy she
should be asking for mercy she
tell me more about that
no i think mercy she should be asking
for forgiveness because she's asking for
help from
from people that she was at war with and
i just believe that you know she needs
counseling and psychiatric help maybe
antidepressants
she's she's very young she doesn't
understand she's
she hasn't been you know she needs
exposure
and if through counseling and like for
me for
my situation i had the ability i had
um to do lots of reading and
it enriched my mind and i realized how
wrong
i had been and it made me so regretful
and
and that's why i do what i do i speak
out in public because
i feel i have to make up for the wrong
that i did being part of this
this propaganda run by osama bin laden
to begin with and i just you know i feel
she was a smart girl she did really well
at school better than i ever did
in high school and i feel that this she
she can be taught she can learn
and we need to help her for the sake of
her child
because if we can help her that's good
for the child it's good for society and
i just only i hope that the british
public can have mercy on her she
she's she's still only 19 and she's been
in for four years she's been around
a group of very draconian like
brutal people who who
really just don't are not in tune with
the 21st century
and i believe that through education we
can enlighten her
and how long did your rehabilitation
take
uh tanya because it's interesting you
say that you felt regretful
when did you start to understand what
you had done and
feel remorse because what a lot of
people are recognizing in shamina
bacon's interview with our correspondent
john sparks
is that she doesn't seem to show any
sign of remorse in fact she said that
she doesn't regret her decision at this
stage
it's despicable i
i was mad i i was very upset when i
heard what she had to say but i also
know she's a 19 year old and they're not
mature
and you can't put an age on maturity 18
does not make
a difference between it is one size
doesn't fit all
um and you know being around the people
that she's been she's had no choice but
to think the way she does for me in my
case i lived in america
and i i i appreciated american values
to the extent that my husband hated me
for it
and so it took so
from 2009 was when i started to stop
believing
and then my husband resented me for that
and he thought i was holding him back
from his religious duties
so he took me to egypt to suppress me
further but
that just enraged me even more because
egypt cairo places they're pretty modern
it's like half half
half a religious half and not religious
and i was still
still felt like i was missing i yeah i i
was i felt like i was missing out i felt
like
so you'd already you'd already started
to feel remorse and regret your
decisions
when you were you know even before you
went to syria and then that made you
leave syria
but yeah if you're in the mindset that
shamim appears to be in now where she
doesn't regret her decision so you know
rewind it back a bit to a point in your
life when you felt like that
how difficult do you think it would have
been to rehabilitate you then to get you
to change your mind
it's a very tricky answer a question to
answer um
i think i just needed i i needed an
answer nobody
at 19 years old when i from 17 to 19
that's when i became very radical
i i wasn't hearing a good argument that
nobody could
understand what was going through my
mind i was
they didn't understand that i i turned
to religion as a coping mechanism
to to cope with my depression
but i really would have liked to i've
heard a voice of reason
um and also good role models in my life
that that was something that was
not present in my life when i was
growing up and
i think shinrimo was in a similar
situation where she
she didn't maybe she felt like an
outcast being
bengali being from an immigrant family
being
not well off in the uk i don't think she
felt maybe she felt and her friends felt
that they didn't have a lot of
opportunity i'm i'm not really sure i
can only speak for myself but that i
know that's how i felt
yeah tanya what would you what would
your advice be to me
my advice would be to correspond with me
for the next 10 years
and let me counsel her so
i i really want to reach out to her and
other people who
are returning from islamic state and i
want to give be that voice of reason
i want to be that role model in their
life that they didn't have
and explain to them that they can change
and really i want to break through that
fear factor that they have
they right now as as extremist muslims
they don't believe in freedom of
thought because they're indoctrinated
and
they have been taught not to question
the islamic beliefs they're not not to
question sharia or god
but we live in a society a free society
where we can question
everything and that's the only way we
can
get to the truth and i just want to like
explain to her
a secular humanist perspective and
explain to her how
you know there are ways of getting
involved with the political process
without violence
to to change whatever whatever they're
disgruntled about about the system but
it takes patience and and non-violence
is the way forward
there's so many things i want to say to
her and others um
that that i it took me a long time to
learn but it's
it is very liberating and enlightening
and i really want that
for her so that to benefit her child